in this video we'll talk about lactose
intolerance
this is a situation when we are unable
to fully digest the sugar lactose which
is present in the milk this results in
diarrhea gas bloating sensation and
abdominal pain lactose intolerance is
kind of harmless but the symptoms
associated with it is kind of
uncomfortable who like that bloated
feeling right
if you're wondering who can develop
develop lactose intolerant then let me
tell you that throughout the world
almost 40 percent of the human
population cannot digest lactose and we
lose our capability of digesting lactose
after two years of age
global population shows that many people
across the age group are lactose
intolerant if we consider u.s population
one third of the population is actually
lactose intolerant
now let's look at the biology behind
this lactose intolerance
whenever we consume milk the lactose
sugar is kind of broken down with the
help of an enzyme lactase
so lactose would be broken down into
subsequent
small parts like glucose and galactose
in order for the body to utilize these
sugars to produce energy they need it in
the simplest form like glucose
so
lactose has to be
converted into glucose right in order
for body to consume it
now this is totally happening with the
help of this enzyme
and this enzyme is produced by the
intestinal epithelial cell
there are specific lacto-lactic gene
that give rise to lactase mrna and
ultimately produce the protein which
leads to
digestion of the lactose and breaking
down into glucose and galactose
now lactose enzyme level decreases as we
age and the gene expression also
decreases
so when we age
less lactase is produced and that makes
a lot of sense
imagine you are a newborn baby so you
are solely dependent on breast milk and
you have to digest that breast milk in
order to
get energy right
so it makes sense you have more and more
lactase enzyme but when the baby is
growing and eat stuf and the baby has
started eating many other foods
then he has alternative source of energy
and carbohydrates which can be utilized
to generate energy
that's why the lactase levels also drop
now
in this case the lactase gene expression
decreases as a result less protein is
produced
thereby
all of the lactose cannot get converted
into glucose and galactose so imagine
you have taken a lot of milk
and there are lot of lactose which has
to be broken down in order to be
consumed by the body
but many of that cannot be digested
because we have very less enzyme
and in that case there are several
bacteria in our colon and digestive
system which can actually utilize
lactose and feast on these lactose they
produce gas and short chain fatty acid
from these lactose
this gas actually leads to that bloated
sensation in our stomach and leads to
the abdominal discomfort
now how do you know that you are lactose
intolerant now simply
whenever you have milk if you feel that
you feel there is a bloating sensation
abdominal pain most likely you are
lactose intolerant
but there are certain tests such as the
hydrogen great test
so you would be having hydrogen in your
air when you excel if you are lactose
intolerant because the bacteria produce
a lot of hydrogen in our stomach in our
colon and that can come out in the
breath
other than that there are blood tests
which are not frequently used the
symptoms are good enough indication to
tell you that you are lactose intolerant
anyway lactose intolerant comes with gas
literally lens discomfort and many of
these things so what is the solution for
this should i quit milk or what should i
do
there are now lactose free milk which
can be consumed
to like overcome the problem
other than that there are alternatives
to cow milk such as soy milk almond milk
which are nutritious but at the same
time doesn't have the lactose and
lactose sugar in that so no problem of
digesting that lactose
so i hope this video is useful if you
like this video give it a big thumbs up
you can get all the notes and flash
cards associated with many topics in my
facebook page link is in the description
don't forget to follow
in the facebook page you would see there
are many dynamic flash cards which are
really helpful for revisions as usual
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can support my channel in patreon if
you are indian user you can use this qr
code to pay me via theme
and my courses are present in unacademy
which is india's biggest online learning
platform using my code ap 10 you can get
a 10 discount see you in the